Yo !
Bienvenue dans cet épisode de Ask !
Alors Ask, c'est toutes les deux ou trois semaines,
C'est un format court où je répondrai à une ou plusieurs questions
que vous, oui vous, cher internaute
m'avez posé
et plus t'en poses, plus t'en as
ask, voilà
Alors je précise direct que ça n'aura aucune incidence sur la fréquence des posts du Coup de Phil'
en gros, c'est comme la FAQ de philo que j'avais fait en février dernier
sauf que, je répond qu'à une ou deux questions
et l'idée c'est genre de faire une sorte de fil rouge autour de ces questions que je reçois, très régulièrement.
Et non de faire une vidéo de 15/20 minutes de temps en temps.
Alors ce sera des questions
du coup, de philo, mais aussi de psycho,
ça peut déborder sur, je sais pas moi, du sociétal, de la science.
Bref, voilà, pour l'instant on va pas se restreindre.
Et bah, c'est parti mes amis,
premier épisode,
de Ask !
Aujourd'hui donc, une question de Roger Van Teub
alors, visiblement, hein, un homme de goût, un homme d'élégance.
Roger Van Teub qui nous demande,
qu'est ce qui définit le Bien et le Mal et rajoute qu'est-ce qui fait que le Bien est bien et le Mal est mal ?
Alors, ces deux notions, c'est avant tout des limites,
parce qu'on a besoin de se donner des limites,
et des repères
lorsqu'on décide de vivre ensemble.
Un peu comme quand tu décides de te mettre en colocation.
Ces deux concepts de Bien et de Mal, ils sont ancestraux.
Ils ont été définis entre autre avec la religion, Dieu il a donné des règles,
comme, par exemple, les Dix Commandements.
Alors, en gros, les respecter c'est bien, ne pas les respecter, c'est mal.
Ensuite, on remarque que...
c'est des notions qui sont entourées d'autres notions
genre, par exemple, le Bien il doit nous mener au bonheur, le Mal mène au malheur, tu vois.
Et même, les Grecs ils vont plus loin en y associant le Beau.
Genre, pour les Grecs, il y avait un vrai idéal du Beau et du Bon.
C'est ce qui s'appelle : Kalos Kagathos
Le Beau était une vertu, et donc il fallait travailler cette vertu comme une autre.
Donc, si vous faites l'erreur de dire à une fille qu'elle est bonne,
n'hésitez pas à faire appel au Khalos Kagathos, hein.
Un petit conseil hein... même si ça m'étonnerait que ça marche.
D'ailleurs, pour fermer cette parenthèse, voici un graphique du site OkCupid.
C'est un site de rencontre où on a demandé aux gens de noter les autres utilisateurs,
suivant leur beauté et leur personnalité
et on remarque que c'est plutôt linéaire.
C'est à dire que, généralement, t'as de la personnalité si t'es beau, voilà.
Donc, bon, Bien et Mal entraînent beaucoup de notions avec eux,
c'est difficile de les penser de manière absolue.
Déjà, parce qu'ils se définissent en partie déjà entre eux, tu vois,
genre ça c'est la définition de bien sur internet
et ensuite parce suivant un point de vue, une même chose peut être bien ou mal.
Genre, par exemple, les livres physiques,
les libraires et écologistes n'auront pas les mêmes points de vue.
genre la vente des livres physiques.
Après, t'as aussi certaines actions qui peuvent être faites avec une bonne intention
et déboucher sur un résultat mauvais.
Donc, bref, le Mal et le Bien de manière absolue, pour moi, ça n'existe pas.
Et ça c'est une pensée plutôt athée.
Parce qu'un croyant a de grandes chances de te dire que si, ça existe et que c'est Dieu le Bien absolu.
D'ailleurs, je précise qu'à chaque fois, je donnerai grosso-modo mon opinion
que j'essaierai de nuancer au maximum
mais je peux pas vous faire tous les points de vue sur une question
c'est juste pas possible.
Donc ce qui est bien et ce qui est mal, sont, à mon sens, subjectifs,
si tu prends Sparte au temps où on tuait les bébés malformés
et que tu demandes à un mec de l'époque si c'est mal
il y a beaucoup de chances qu'il te dise que c'est pas mal.
Il te dira que c'est la règle,
qu'il est pour ou contre,
mais pas que c'est mal de tuer des bébés malformés.
En fait, ce qu'il faut comprendre,
c'est que tuer, par exemple, n'est pas absolument mal avec un "m" majuscule.
C'est très chaud de le comprendre pour nous
tellement l'inverse est ancré dans notre esprit.
On le voit comme tel, parce qu'on a grandi dans un cadre avec une morale
une éthique,
dans un pays, en plus, qui a aboli la peine de mort.
Au passage, la dernière exécution à la guillotine c'était en...
1977, je crois,
donc c'était, euh,
c'était même
il me semble
après la date de sortie du premier Star Wars.
Donc euh,
on est pas,
on est pas des pointes.
Voilà, si tu regardes les animaux qui s'entretuent,
c'est ni mal ni bien.
Bien et mal, ça n'a pas de sens dans la nature.
C'est des concepts qui sont inventés par l'Homme.
Alors après, bien sûr !
C'est bon ou mauvais par rapport à une éthique,
par rapport à une morale.
Mais c'est pas Bien ou Mal en soi
avec un "b" et un "m" majuscules.
Voilà.
J'espère que c'est
alors, par contre, on pourrait parler
de ce qui est bien pour,
comment dire,
de ce que peut représenter le Bien pour chaque philosophe.
Genre, par exemple, pour Platon, c'est un idéal auquel on doit se rapprocher.
Pour Aristote,
c'est le développement maximal, pour chaque être, de sa nature propre.
Pour les "Ecuriens", les Épicuriens, pardon,
ça va être, le bonheur.
Voilà, c'est
En gros, pour te dire pourquoi tu as du mal à définir ces notions,
c'est tout simplement parce que c'est des notions qui ne se définissent pas toutes seules.
Voilà, j'espère que ça répond à ta question
et que c'est plus clair pour toi.
Autre question de Steven Wreco
Alors,
déjà une question qui se pose
est-ce qu'il y a des libertés sans limites ?
Moi, je pense pas.
C'est à dire que quoi que tu fasses,
t'es limité par quelque chose.
Même si t'es tout seul dans la société
t'es quand même limité.
Déjà par ton environnement
ensuite par les lois de la physique
ensuite par toi-même
genre avec le Surmoi par exemple.
Bref, il y a des tonnes de limites à la liberté.
Donc oui, puisqu'une liberté a presque toujours des limites.
Maintenant, la question c'est à partir de quand ces limites deviennent assez fortes
pour qu'on ne puisse plus parler de liberté.
Donc ta question elle pose l'étude de cette échelle
des limites
mais pas que,
par exemple, un mec en prison
bah, il est pas libre
parce qu'il peut pas aller où il veut
mais peut toujours dire ce qu'il pense
il est toujours libre de penser ce qu'il veut,
donc, ça dépend de quelle liberté on parle aussi.
Alors, j'ai essayé de trouver une classification des libertés,
mais j'ai pas trouvé grand chose
Donc voilà, si quelqu'un a des infos là dessus
qu'il n'hésite pas à lâcher un commentaire ou à envoyer un tweet
Après on pourrait dire que la liberté c'est de pouvoir faire ce qu'on veut.
Et, dans ce cas
rien ne nous dit que le mec en prison ne veut pas rester dans sa cellule
et donc au final, il fait ce qu'il veut
et donc qu'il est, dans un sens, libre.
Bon, je vais pas rajouter de la subjectivité à ta question
sinon on s'en sort plus.
Mais voilà, en gros,
si je devais répondre hyper simplement
je dirais que je pense que oui,
une liberté est réellement une liberté si on lui fixe des limites
puisque
la liberté absolue n'existe pas pour nous, pauvres humains
que nous sommes.
Et je t'envoie la dernière vidéo de Minute Papillon
sur la liberté, qui est excellente.
je la mets dans la description.
Et j'espère que...
c'est maintenant plus clair pour toi.
Voilà.
C'est tout !
C'est tout pour ce premier épisode.
J'espère que ça vous a plu !
Parce qu'à moi ça m'a plu.
Si vous voulez poser une question, n'hésitez pas !
Il suffit d'aller sur le post de cette vidéo, sur la page Facebook.
Donc le lien de la page Facebook c'est dans la description
et le prochain Ask sera, à priori, un live
donc je vous tiendrai informés sur Facebook et Twitter
de comment ça va se passer
je vous avoue que...
actuellement, je n'ai aucune idée de comment ça va se passer
absolument aucune idée !
Quand je dis absolument, c'est absolument,
pas subjectivement ou relativement.
Voilà !
J'espère que ça vous a plu,
je vous envoie du Love
et de la Peace
Ciao !
Bye !